الطاهيه الفلسطينيه سلام دقاق صاحبه مطعم
بيت مريم في دبي استطاعت ان تفوز بجائزه
افضل طهيه في منطقه شرق الاوسط بعد
التصويت الذي سجلته اكاديميه افضل خمسين
مطعما في الشرق الاوسط وشمال افريقيا وهي
جائزه لن يسبق لاي احد من المنطقه العربيه
الحصول عليها تتميز اطباق الشيف سلام
بانها تجول حول عده بلدان عربيه من الخليج
الذي عاشت فيه الى بلاد الشام الذي اتت
منها فهي تقدم اطباقا تقليديه يعشقها
العرب طريقه استقبال الشاف سلام الزبائن
هي اكثر ما تشتهر به فهي تعتبر لان
الاستقبال هو اول ما يجب على الطهي الجيد
ان يتمتع به وتشدد على اهميه معامله
الزبائن بطريقه حميميه وكسر الحواجز
وتشعرهم وكانهم ياكلون في المنزل
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
وتنورنا بحضورها معانا في الاستديو اليوم
شايف سلام دقائق شايف اهلا بك
مبروك عليك الفوز الله يبارك فيك
كيف كان شعورك بهذا الفوز اول شيء صباح
الخير ويسعد صباحكم شكرا لاستضافتي
كان شعور كثير رائع صراحه كانت في حفاوه
مش معقوله يمكن انا ما سمعتها قبل
سمعوها وراي همم كان كثير الحضور وكل
هالحفله كانت جميله جدا
وحسيت حالي هيك مميزه انبسطت كثير طبعا
يعني كمان جوائز متزوجه كمان شاف سلام همم
نساء ملهمات فوق الخمسين يعني كله جوائز
واحتفالات السعاده والنجاح دائما
شاف سلامتك
اتغديني اه يعني دائما عندك الاهتمام
والدلال قبل فكره الاكله شو بتحكي لنا
حبيبتي نادين تعرفي شو كثير في مطاعم وانا
في دوله ام المطاعم يعني همم ما بدي اكسر
قاعده انه بس بدنا نفوت على المطعم ناكل
ونطلع لا انا بدي احسس كل زبون وهذا ما
بيلاقيم اطباقي انك انت فايت على بيتك انا
عامله وظيفه امن همم بدي اكسر حاجه اني
انا فايت علامات بدي اكل بس الصحن وشوكه
بالسكينه لا اهوت على البيت تحس حالك
مرتاح وكلها بغربه كلنا محتاجين لهاي
الروح الحلوه همم
صاحبه المطعم موجوده
بالنسبه للاطباق اللي فزتي فيها شو اللي
خلى الشيف سلام تفوز بهذه الاطباق شو
المعايير اللي فيها يمكن اول اشي كلها
هاي كتير مهمه مطبوخه بحب مطبوخه من ام
لاولادها فانا كل يوم فعلا بطبخ الطبخه
كانه لاولادي عشان يجوا يستمتعوا وينبسطوا
بلقمتهم حتى لما بتعاملي الناس بنشوف على
السوشيال ميديا بتدلليهم كانه اولاد يعني
هذا اللي بنحتاجه بالغربه طيب وشاف سلام
انا بسمع كمان انه انت رسامه وبتحب الرسم
يعني على ما يبدو انت مياله للفن على
انواعه قديه كمان الطبخ يجب انه يكون لما
نسمع دائما بنقول الطبخ نفس الاكل نفس
الجمله دقيقه ولا بس جمله رقيقه هي نفس شو
يعني يعني انت ضايقتي يعني عارفه شو حاطه
شو انجريديانز شو في وكتير له علاقه الرسم
بالطبخ الفن كله حتى الطبخ فن ما هو يعني
مش همم كيف تحطي المقادير مع بعض كيف
تزبطي النكهات كيف تطلع بيرفكت الملحات
البهارات تبعونها هذا كله في تقنيه يعني
واحنا اكيد راح يكون لنا زياره ان شاء
الله
بتشرف فيكم عنجد ونحن اكثر هو بيتكم وشكرا
لوجودك معنا وشكرا لوقتك حبيبتي